[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 voici les
titres
30 km heure dans les rues à partir du
1er janvier 2023 après Manille léamo
Poissy ou encore Villepreux c'est au
Vésinet qu'il faudra bientôt lever le
pied amante c'est la hausse des tarifs
municipaux qui risquent de ne pas
satisfaire le portefeuille démonté en
2023 la réévaluation est estimée après
de
3,5%. elle concerne notamment l'accès au
lieu culturel et la location des salles
communales nous vous en parlerons dans
les informations du jour à Versailles
l'origami gérardis Sauvan expose plus de
3000 créations en papier l'exposition
zoo de papier est à découvrir jusqu'au
29 janvier 2023 à l'espace Richaud
Julien Le Roy nous fera découvrir l'un
de l'artiste qui vous le verrez facile
aussi bien les enfants que les adultes
et en pleine transformation l'espace
Kyos dev va intégrer de nouvelles
enseignes parmi les différentes
activités un espace d'escalade à ouvert
le 17 décembre dernier Nicolas dandry
revient sur les transformations en cours
et les activités qui verront le jour le
point maintenant sur l'information du
jour avec Céline Charles
après Manille et hameaux c'est au
Vésinet qu'il faudra désormais lever le
pied à partir du 1er janvier la vitesse
dans les rues sera limitée à 30 km/h ce
changement a pour but d'améliorer la
sécurité routière de réduire les
nuisances sonores et de permettre une
meilleure cohabitation avec les piétons
et cyclistes les routes départementales
restent quant à elle à 50 km/h le
porte-monnaie des mentais va être mise à
rude épreuve en 2023 pour faire face à
l'inflation et la hausse des tarifs la
ville de Mantes-la-Jolie va évaluer de
3,5%, la quasi-totalité de ces tarifs
municipaux cela concerne par exemple la
localisation des salles communales
l'accès au lieu et activités culturelles
ou encore les concessions funéraires une
erreur administrative qui coûte cher à
l'AS Poissy en une semaine le club qui
était sur le podium du groupe A de
National 2 a perdu 7 points sur le
nouveau classement publiée par la
Fédération Française de foot en cause
les certificats médicaux figurants sur
les demandes de licence 2022 2023 de
deux joueurs qui ne présenteraient pas
les garanties d'authenticité nécessaire
la commission régionale de discipline à
donner gain de cause à Rouen avec qui
laisse Poissy à disputer un match le 10
septembre dernier en leur donnant la
victoire sur tapis vert avec quatre
points en moins pour Poissy le club
c'est également vu retirer un point en
moins pour les trois rencontres
précédentes Rennes Blois et Granville le
club pourrait faire appel de la décision
plus que quelques jours avant le
réveillon de Noël et si certains d'entre
vous se demandent déjà comment se
débarrasser de son sapin après les
festivités le calendrier de la collecte
des sapins naturels a été donnée dans
plusieurs villes à Guyancourt le
ramassage se fera le 9 janvier 2023 le
10 janvier pour Montigny-le-Bretonneux
les deux villes mettent également à
disposition des lieux de collecte à
partir du 26 décembre les collectes en
porte-à-porte seront supprimés pour la
plupart des villes de la communauté
d'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc au
profit des lieux de collecte plus de
renseignements sur le site Internet de
votre ville et enfin pour ceux qui
seraient inquiets quant au bon
déroulement de la tournée du Père Noël
pas de panique le maire de la ville de
Beynes vient de signer un arrêté les
bancs de recharge électrique de la ville
seront exclusivement réservés au Père
Noël dans la nuit du 24 au 25 décembre
décembre toutes les personnes
stationnées en devant les bornes verront
leur véhicule transformés en traîneaux
et si vous aussi vous voyez une
information près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager avec le hashtag
78 news sur nos réseaux sociaux
lors du pliage pour patient l'artiste
Girardi Sauvan expose son zoo de papier
en origami à l'espace richo de
Versailles une technique consistante à
plier une seule feuille pour la création
de ses animaux papier peint pour les
éléments les plus petits et papier kraft
pour une meilleure tenue des grandes
œuvres oh vous faites le premier pli ça
permet mais comme sur la deuxième les
uns superposés sur les autres et ça
bloque comme une chaîne d'un maillon et
quand pour les fesses c'est pas facile
il faut connaître l'endroit où vous
pouvez démonter sinon ça risque de
déchirer un travail de minutie pour cet
artiste originaire du Cambodge des sons
plus jeune âge sa grand-mère l'initie
aux bases de cette technique d'origine
chinoise il réalise ensuite des oeuvres
de plus en plus complexes sur des
animaux une fascination pour ses êtres
leur forme et leur couleur par exemple
comme un oiseau
je ne sais pas qui a créé pourquoi le
bec jaune
les yeux bleus les plumes
flamboyants c'est incroyable
j'aime beaucoup les oiseaux qu'il y a et
les chiens aussi et les minuscules
pliages de l'infiniment petit pour ces
éléphants faits de feuilles de 4 mm de
côté à l'infiniment grand avec cette
girafe de 3 mètres de haut ces oeuvres
d'une grande finesse représentant des
insectes ont été réalisés avec du papier
de soie ça permet pour avoir les pattes
le plus fine possible aucun cours de
ciseaux le papier ça fait 80 cm de côté
j'ai plein de tortues très bien
dessinées et en plus il y avait il y a
aussi en origami des filets de mer donc
pour représenter la pollution de la mer
donc c'était très intéressant et un bel
engagement environ 3000 origamis sont
exposés à l'espace riche au de
Versailles petits et grands sont conviés
à cette invitation au voyage jusqu'au 29
janvier 2023
et vous venez de voir le reportage de
Julien Leroy cette exposition fait aussi
l'objet d'un vyb à retrouver très
prochainement sur TV 78 en parlant de Vy
P notamment nous vous proposons ce soir
un extrait de l'émission de Patrice
Carmaux il recevait Didier Kimmel auteur
du livre Les roses bleues sélectionnez
pour le festival francophone l'auteur
revient sur son voyage à New York et ses
rencontres ça a été un moment magique
bien naturellement parce que encore une
fois quand j'ai écrit ce roman je
t’éloigne imaginer que j'aurai
l'opportunité de me rendre à New York
c'est quand même des petits salons
d'auteur pourquoi pas mais voilà c'est
ça donc je remercie toujours bien sûr
Sandrine de m'avoir convié parce que
c'était un moment formidable d'ailleurs
c'était intéressant parce que en fait
c'est 30 auteurs on se connaît plutôt
via les visioconférences il y a
quelques-uns qu'on rencontre le plus
souvent c'est par connexion etc et là
c'était une journée finalement oui mais
en fait comme ils sont de plusieurs pays
comme on l'avait compris on n'est pas on
est pas certain du tout de se rencontrer
et là ça a été l'occasion à nous 32 nous
rencontrer et Sandrine avait organisé
une journée finalement qui a débuté par
un petit déjeuner dans un endroit fort
sympathique où là on a pu effectivement
ce connaît discuter et puis c'est de la
discussion que ressort aussi
l'envie d'écrire les encouragements
l'inspiration pourquoi pas et de voir
tous ces expériences partager tous ces
expériences là ça a été vraiment un
moment magnifique donc ça c'était le
matin et puis l'après-midi donc on a eu
ce salon dans un endroit encore une fois
tout à fait prestigieux avec la chance
mais incroyable de voir quelqu'un comme
Marc Levy qui est quand même
plus dans le monde aujourd'hui
les sympathie d'une simplicité et qui
est venue nous porter une parole nous
encourager vraiment ça ça a été pour
nous tous très touchants parce que c'est
quand même un monsieur nous on est
vraiment minuscule à côté de lui et il a
été vraiment d'une sympathie romantique
et mercredi à lieu le dernier après-midi
au centre social du pont du routoir à
Guyancourt quatre familles sont venues
participer à un atelier de pâtisserie
elles ont pu passer un dernier moment de
2022 ensemble dans cette infrastructure
municipale un moment de convivialité
pour les enfants qui ont pu se retrouver
on écoute Nissa benez référente famille
au centre social du pont du routoir à
Guyancourt l'objectif c'est pas du tout
de faire un cours de cuisine ou un cours
de pâtisserie c'est d'avoir un moment
convivial de profiter ensemble parents
et enfants et d'avoir vraiment un moment
festif de fin d'année sympa c'est ce
genre d'événements a lieu tout au long
de l'année on a une programmation
trimestrielle qui balaye vraiment toute
l'année avec des ateliers culinaires des
ateliers créatifs des moments festifs on
essaye de proposer vraiment un grand
panorama d'activités pour que les
familles puissent venir profiter du
centre social de l'équipement et puis
s'en servir et être moteur dans la
programmation qu'on propose et pas
d'inquiétude car ces ateliers font leur
retour en 2023 premier rendez-vous le
mercredi 11 janvier de 9 à 10 heures
autour de l'éveil musical pour les
enfants jusqu'à 6 ans avec une
musicienne sensorielle un mot maintenant
sur l'espace Skywest maintenant ce
dernier va intégrer de nouvelles
enseignes d'ici la fin du premier
semestre 2023 inauguré en 2005 et en
pleine transformation suite à son rachat
en 2020 par la Société des grands
magasins de nombreuses activités
ludiques vont être proposées le
reportage de Nicolas dandry c'est la
première enseigne à inaugurer la
mutation de Skywest ce nouvel espace
d'escalade a ouvert le 17 décembre
dernier avec différentes activités tout
public il y a des niveaux de difficultés
donc pour les tout-petits il y a des il
y a des petits parcours adaptés à
l'orage et puis après les plus
téméraires pourront aller jusqu'à 10
mètres 11 mètres de haut mais le gros du
chantier actuellement c'est pour
l'ouverture mi-janvier d'un espace de
loisirs sur deux étages bowling billard
karaoké et même un karting électrique
c'est quelque chose de
d'unique dans un centre commercial avec
en particulier du karting électrique qui
passera quand vous le verrez tout à
l'heure dans dans le mail en plein
centre et en plein milieu des visiteurs
ces nouvelles enseignes s'inscrivent
dans la stratégie du nouveau
propriétaire la société des grands
magasins a racheté le centre Skywest en
mai 2020 on a démoli tous les niveaux
inférieurs qui étaient fermés depuis de
nombreuses années donc on en a profité
pour tout raser et on a étudié tous les
différents projets pour aboutir un gros
parc de loisirs qu'on va installer et
qu'on va ouvrir sur cette fin d'année
2022 et de début d'année 2023 en fait
l'idée c'est à partir du mois de janvier
nous aurons une ouverture par mois donc
SpeedPark
le trampoline Park
et derrière une surprise les discussions
sont toujours en cours les ouvertures se
succéderont durant le premier semestre
2023 un renouveau qui arrive près de 20
ans après son inauguration en 2005
et comme chaque jeudi nous vous
proposons nos idées sorties nous avons
sélectionné 5 idées de sortie à faire en
famille ou entre amis pendant les
vacances de Noël voici la sélection de
Mélanie pocket
[Musique]
à quelques jours de Noël vous allez
peut-être prendre la route pour
rejoindre vos proches ou partir en
vacances voici les prévisions de Bison
Futé ce jeudi 22 décembre était orange
dans le sens des départs et des retours
en Île-de-France pour ce qui est de
vendredi vous le voyez Bison Futé
annonce orange pour les départs quitter
ou traverser la région avant 10h il est
aussi conseillé d'éviter l'autoroute A10
à hauteur du pH de Saint-Arnoult de 10h
à 15h pour les retours tous les voyants
sont au vert et avant de se quitter je
vous propose de faire un petit point sur
la météo de demain je l'appuie
de la pluie est prévue sur l'ensemble
des Yvelines du côté des températures le
temps continue de s'adoucir compter 12
degrés à Rambouillet 13 à Versailles
mentent la jolie et Houdan l'après-midi
toujours de la pluie mais avec un ciel
plus ensoleillé les températures seront
comprises entre 13 et 14 degrés sur
l'ensemble du département et demain nous
fêterons les armans et c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité nous vous donnons rendez-vous
très bientôt en attendant je vous
souhaite de très belles fêtes de fin
d'année et une très belle soirée sur TV
[Musique]